thank you very much and everyone hear me
I'm right very honored to be able to
come here and be able to interact with
some of the grad students we went out to
dinner and had a good time
I probably ordered the wrong stuff some
hot food but that was okay I actually
have a fair amount of connection with
Cornell people in the past I think
particularly those of you that are
graduate students ought to realize how
fortunate you are to be able to work at
an institution which has a lot of depths
in in the different areas of plant
biology and just the people that that
are your matters mentors they're
well-known people of the world and in my
interactions throughout my career it
I've met so many people and I find oh my
god she's piece from Cornell she's from
Cornell you know Cornell it has a
reputation for or graduating a lot of
people I realize there's a lot of
molecular work and bigger focus on the
molecular end of things but what I've
noticed over my career is is that a lot
of the people I've interacted with have
good basic knowledge but they're also
able to reach out to the growers and and
of course in I do revert a lot of very
applied work and having and so I have a
lot of interaction with vegetable
growers and there's just a number of
people from Cornell that that I've seen
over the years interact well and give a
lot of information they take the basic
information and bring it down to the
growers level and this this will always
continue to be important regardless of
the balance of research that's going on
the information in agriculture at some
point has to to get to the grower
and I think think some institutions lose
sight of this and there's been several
people from Cornell that have have given
me some assistance of the year
Molly John Henry Munger passed away some
years back
Tom's it er pathologist has helped me
out and sending me cultures and
diagnosing certain disease problems that
we had and just a number of people and
have also met a lot of people I used to
work in agricultural plastics a lot and
it turns out the number probably because
of the particular expertise at Cornell
University
a lot of those people were trained at
Cornell University and so so anyway this
is a real honor to be able to speak to
you and we'll get started here so your
carpet uh I do melon breeding but I'm
not going to talk about that at all cue
carpet is an extremely interesting crop
in all the species originated in
America's and North and South America
some of them had an extremely early date
and start off with C Maxima on the
bottom originated in and we know the
wild species it's the progenitor of C
maxima and and the interesting thing is
the distribution of this particular
species by the time the Europeans
colonized the Americas the distribution
was probably about like that and it
didn't it wasn't up in in the United
States or Central America and and we
don't have a lot of archaeological sites
where they've recovered Maxima it goes
back maybe three or four or five
thousand years ago the domestication but
it's one of the younger species oficer
Foley I'm not going to talk about it
grows at high altitude it will not its
will not enter cross with any of the
other domesticated species it has very
little variation so it's almost
monotypic but it's adapted to very high
elevations and not has not found a lot
of worldwide youth q carboneau mushara
is the that's the truck one species it's
most adapted to the tropics and that's
probably affected how it was distributed
it was originally thought to have
originated in Mexico because there were
archeological dates for its existence
going back like 6,000 years ago but now
they have samples that they've been able
to get from from sites in this area to
go back about ten thousand nine to ten
thousand years ago and it's usually in
these are archaeological sites the
material is preserved or seeds and
fruits pieces of fruit wine but it's you
see the seeds that characterized the
particularly if we have the stem of the
fruit the peduncle of the fruit we can
also characterize varieties that way and
so it is thought that it originated here
because there's a lot of variation and a
lot of very relic varieties that exist
in colombia I'm not going to talk about
a gyruss firma
it's mainly used for its seeds and it
hasn't been utilized
much throughout the world to carve it a
couple people sub specie people
originated in this area and again it
goes back at least 9,000 years and
there's been several archaeological
sites where they found this particular
species and there's another sub species
of people or viscera and it's quite
interesting that these two species the
wild species from which the liver came
exists down in this area
are in up into this area and so we know
the wild progenitor of this particular
species in the Native Americans
introduced and bred this species going
back about five thousand years ago and
it spread throughout the eastern half of
the u.s. not so much over in the western
half of the US whereas this species
originated and there's archaeological
sites down in southern Mexico and also
along in this area the state of Tamil
APIs in Mexico and the most interesting
thing is is even though these species
are easily possible you know you could
almost consider them one species but but
there was not there was no contact we
don't have any knowledge of contact
prior to the Europeans coming that these
species ever crossed with each other so
that it's very unusual to find two
species that were domesticated so close
to one another yes sir well apparently
was not a lot of human contact and so
there wasn't a lot of inner crossing of
these these particular species so the
variation of this species is well
documented and so I'm going to more talk
about the variation that relates to my
breeding programs but you can go back
into herbals back into the sixteenth
century
and see quite a number of quite a bit of
variation in in in in the species
because the Europeans when they came
over and conquered some of the countries
they brought back the fruit to Europe
and do Shayne's drawings in 1786 natural
history the gourds it shows about all
the phenotypes that exist today in
Cheaper by the peoples subspecies of
different and excuse me and then the
vegetable garden is Connie
to look at it because it shows the state
of of the variation in in cucurbits and
other vegetables existing in the 19th
century and then the cucurbits
vegetables in New York that's always a
there's a whole series of vegetables of
New York that was published back then
and and I have copies of several the
vegetables and they're just fun to look
at and there's and there's a whole lot
of books the complete squash by Amie
Goldman was probably one of the best of
them this is this is what what was in my
greenhouse three weeks ago that came
from the field and I would just have to
tell you that that all of variation that
you see in all those catalogs and stuff
good share of it exists from this
particular photo I work with all three
species and the two subspecies and it's
almost it's almost overwhelming it's a
very daunting task for me at this stage
in my career and these all involve
selections and we have to do cooking
tests and various evaluations on all
these squash in these two pictures so
cue carbonyl Maxima just to refresh your
interest or fresh your knowledge of it
the the main cue carbon the Maxima that
you see in supermarkets as kabocha or
buttercup we generally call a squash
buttercup it has a protruding ovary
whereas we in Asian countries they've
gotten rid of that and it's called
kabocha squash but that's a general term
in Haeju for for any small squash it
looks like this and so the processing
Golden Delicious is the main processing
squash there are a few hybrids but
mostly just open pollinated and actually
in Argentina you have summer squash
produced they let it grow a little
bigger than our summer squash in order
to get big enough but there they do use
it as a summer squash and then
there's several others that I can't show
but the giant show pumpkin are really
really an anomaly the size is just
unbelievable when those and then if we
go to Cucurbita pepo subspecies a little
different the Acorn group even though
you probably don't think of this as an
acorn this is a delicata type and a
sweet dumpling type but it's all called
the Acorn group and in some books these
the straight Nicks and the crook next
summer squash and the scallops are all
put into separate groups I call them all
summer squashes course that's eaten
immature and I know for some reason in
New England and the Northeast
zucchinis is apini and a summer squash
is a yellow squash they're all summer
squash they're all they're all eaten new
mature okay and then gourds i define
gorgeous is squash having a hard shell
and having some ornamental value and
that's not always the definition getting
and then here's what I mean about you
curb of people subspecies people the one
that was originated and Mexico for one
thing the size is bigger and you'd have
some that are that are quite large you
have quite a lot of variation and color
these are some of my breeding lines I
saw in a store window when we're eating
last night I saw a lot of variation just
look just like this matter of fact it
was all fake pumpkins but plastic
pumpkin it's kind of discouraging and
then in the summer squash arena this is
probably that dominant dominant use of
squashes for summer squash particularly
the zucchini types okay and they they
were derived from the coca zel from
Italy and and these types were were bred
actually in Europe as far as we know
they weren't were were not bred in the
area of origin in Kew carbonyl Masada
I didn't start working with carbon was
shot until just really the last
12 years us all and but I had seed
companies come to me in the 80s
particularly libby's was was breeding a
processing this Dickenson field
processing type and they sent me some
lines to look at and I and I looked at
him a really really poor quality for
edibility
and and I thought well I'm not gonna I'm
not going to work on you carbon in my
shot oh there's it's just it's
butternuts and it's this Dickinson feel
type and I and and the seat gummies they
can do all the work on that I'm not
going to get involved with that well now
it's my biggest breeding project you
know and and and I'll tell you why in a
little bit why I'm so excited about it
and if you're going to into third-world
countries because it's we've adapted
some of these varieties so they grow in
temperate climates and some of these but
the calabaza that exists down in the
Caribbean and there's a lot of varieties
of masada that grow in Southeast Asia
and if you go to India and all the
squash in the market I don't have a
picture one here but later on there's
sort of the large cheese type you see
them in the market it's not type of
quality we would we would think for you
know like a but or not but but
nonetheless they're very popular in in
Asian countries the fruit of squash is a
people technically it's a modified berry
and in the flesh actually is derived
both from the ovary and it's also
derived from from the floral cup or the
receptacle and which makes it
interesting because occasionally you get
a selection and there'll be two colors
to be a real intense color in the in the
ovary part and also in the placental
material and then this how-to ring of
flesh will be totally a different color
I couldn't find a good slide of that to
show you because you could have gene
expression for carotenoids you could
have different expression in the
receptacle tissue versus the ovary
tissue kind of
fascinating it's a monisha flowering
species be pollinated bumblebees are the
most efficient pollinators there's also
a cucurbit B that actually evolved with
squash it needs to have open soil in
order to to nest and so we don't have
very many the squash bees at the farm
they're not quite as efficient as
bumblebees and also honeybees will
pollinate it and so I'm not going to go
into the intricate structure the main
thing is it's monisha separate male and
female flowers and they flower in the
morning okay I would make a beautiful
ornamental plant we have flowers that
are that big I'm not exaggerating and
government of people we have some that
are a foot in diameter beautiful flowers
but they will during the morning okay
and so so in that sense they don't you
couldn't bring them in a house and use
them as an ornamental so this just shows
the different species and they they have
slightly different flower structures and
when you work with them you can kind of
see that this is kind of a bell shaped
and and and this has the very deep lobes
in it and and the Michoud is a little
bit different the thing from a breeding
standpoint what one needs to know is
these flowers wilt down at different
times it's genetically endowed in them
so the kicker Berta people it often will
stem by 9:00 in the form by will stone I
mean the flower it loses its turgor and
when it loses its turgor and the male
flower the pollen loses its lose its
ability to germinate on the stigma so
you have to pollinate in the morning
okay and and so it turns out that that
subspecies or viscera is the first to
wilt down and so we have to pollinate it
by 8:00 or 8:30 then we move over to
this field and it's got
people we can pollinate it depend on how
how cloudy or sunny it is we can
pollinate it late and then them a shot
as we pollinate between 9:30 and 10:30
and then we then we move over the
Maximus it's it's the only way with a
small crew that we can deal with all
these species and get our work done and
we have to go in the day before and we
tie these flowers off and you can tell
when they're going to flower the next
day it is possible you can take a female
flower that's at this stage and you can
pollinate it and it will set fine so you
do have a little bit of leeway you can
also the male Paul and even before it's
shed can can be can fertilized but it's
kind of difficult to get the pollen out
so it's normally we like to have that
flower open so if you look at the head
growth curve the and this happens to be
a seed pumpkin example which is a little
bit extreme because most of the energy
is going into the seeds rather than in
the flesh but a pumpkins and squash
behave like any crop that produces a
storage organ like potatoes and so forth
in other words the vegetative growth
Peaks usually shortly after flowering
and as the Leafs and s it goes downhill
and and then you have in the pericarp
and the flesh of the pumpkins
you have the biomass goes is mainly
going into the flesh here yeah but it's
also going into the seeds so in the peak
the peak dry matter or the flesh occurs
earlier than it does with the seed and
so what actually happens is if the plant
you get too much plants in essence the
seed is still developing in that fruit
and it actually takes away starch
reserves from from the flesh you know
and it's important to know because if
you pick your few
picture fruit too early in development
then here and you want you're interested
in the flesh not the seeds you're gonna
have respiration occurring and you're
also going to have transport of sugars
from the flesh you know starts breakdown
and transport into the seeds so that's
it's important to have the knowledge of
of the growth cycle and this is just
another one it's more detailed work that
we did a graduate student in back in the
late 90s and actually looked at him real
growth because no one had looked at
embryo growth and if I should have had a
picture of a fruit cut open if you cut
open a fruit at 20 days after fruits
that are after pollination if you look
at that fruit you'll say oh the seeds
are fully developed well what it is the
seed coats fully developed not fully
developed it reaches its full size and
the seed size you don't see segregation
for seed size in a fruit it's a maternal
trait and it's determined by the seed
coat which is maternal tissue so that's
why all the seeds even if you have
segregation for seed size you don't see
it until the next generation okay and so
what happens if you opened up that seed
at 20 days I do I should have put in a
picture that but the the embryo is very
small only a couple of millimeters B and
so the embryo reaches near full size in
the next 20 days but it actually
accumulates lipids and proteins up to 55
to 60 days and so it's important to know
the actual fruit growth if you look at
the fruit growth curve depends on the
size of the fruit if it's a small board
actually the the fruit reaches maximum
size in about 12 days and some of the
acorn squash 15 to 18 days and in in
like a pumpkin a 25 pound pumpkin will
reach its full size about 20 faith I'd
be if you're talking about the shell
pumpkins the only reason I know this is
is I give given talks to to these
growers are fanatics about growing these
big
pumpkins [ __ ] farmers that's what they
knew their girl they show pumpkins and
so one had a nice growth curve of a show
pumpkin he majored circumference over
time I was really amazed these so
pumpkins are still growing in girth at
60 days at 60 days it's pretty amazing
quite a different curve from this curve
and again the meso carpet dry weight the
starch content Peaks piece really close
to 30 days 35 days and then it generally
usually goes down again this is with a
seed pumpkin and so again in the case of
the seed pumpkin it's you know it's it
needs mesocarp it needs to get sugars
from the mesocarp so the meso carb goes
down a little in order to feed the
embryo growth and when I talk about
pumpkins to growers this is just a chart
I would show pump and gourd because it's
a little different in a pumpkin all you
need is an orange pumpkin right and so
that color change usually occurs between
25 and 40 40 days after pollination
there's some varieties are a little
later but most most varieties some of
them reach full color by by maybe 32
days after pollination well can you
harvest the grower always ask well can I
harvest my pumpkins right after they
turn once I said yeah go ahead
you know and if you have a healthy plant
the the pea Dunkel will be fine the stem
of the pumpkin that's in bringing
pumpkins that's the most important part
if you don't have a good stem if you
can't carry a pumpkin out of the field
on its stem it it's not good and so it
turns out that cellulose and lignin most
of that is the accumulated and the pre
Dunkel most of it by 30 days and there's
a difference in varieties on that and so
and again it's it's we actually did a
study of pea Dunkel dry matter and dry
weight in pumpkin because you have to
know that okay and in order to know when
when to harvest it but of course the
seeds not mature by then so in my work
my timeline for my cue carpet breeding
projects at UNH my first I was bringing
melons all since I started I won't talk
about melons but it but I started off I
was only breeding working with two
carbon a Maxima for a number of years
and I'll be honest with you my first
variety and Maxima came out in 1981
well that's 13 years of breeding to
produce my first variety that doesn't
say too much maybe about my breeding
experience a very difficult project I
was trying to put Bush genes into a
large fruited processing pumpkin because
there was a huge processing industry in
New England and the Northeast at the
time in the Golden Delicious type and I
had a particular ideal type of pumpkin
that I envisioned a more upright Bush
pumpkin would be more efficient
photosynthetic lean and we did a lot of
background work you know comparing the
the phenotype of the bush and the leaf
area and in light interception and and
so forth I'm not going to go into that
but it was a pretty difficult product
well in in in the lines you see that are
in in dark these are the projects where
I've spent the most research time on but
they're not the projects from a
standpoint to getting something into the
industry we're successful and that's I
think that's how it is an institution
you work on some projects that seed
companies wouldn't necessarily work on
but maybe those will never be successful
at getting something into the seed
industry so with me because I like to
breed an end product I tried to have
enough projects so I could introduce
varieties into the seed market you know
so the growers would think I was
actually doing something at UNH
you know if you're a breeder and you
there for 13 years and you don't have
much to show for it and you go to a
grower meeting you're giving a talk and
they're shaking their head you know what
the hell's lloyd doing you know I mean
that's always bothered me so what
happened to the to this bush strain well
AG wait
and so forth well the processing
companies they're kind of they're back
in the 19th century you know in terms of
their how they space things and so they
were used to growing the processing
pumpkins twelve by twelve and and that
was their cultivation system it doesn't
matter what we told him I could tell him
look you need high-density planning you
need to plant this bush strain you know
close spacing and give them a spacing
but you go out in her field
it was 12 by 12 and they were telling me
well it doesn't yield well no a bush
plant that's that's three to four feet
in diameter at twelve foot space she's
not going to give a very good yield is
it you know so so what happened in New
England by the time I got my first
variety the processing industry was gone
I mean just gone left by the by the
completely by the mid nineteen eighty
five well I continue these lines
processing lines I add them and turns
out now that I'm actually using some of
those process processing lines for
breeding rootstocks for melon okay so so
I'm glad I kind of hung on to the hose
but and the same thing I use the bush
the Bush genes that I've accumulated
because it's it's not just one Bush gene
as you seem to look at you're actually
maximum others we've identified three
Bush genes and so and they're all in
completely DOM and it's so difficult to
work with and so we we have developed a
number of Bush lines high-quality again
all our material was a very low quality
you know in in terms of starch content
and the genes for increasing starch
content it's a quantitative trait
somewhat difficult
Hollis pumpkins I started the work and
was doing a lot of work on you know well
what's the composition of the hall and
this and that and and and had a fair
number of graduate students work on
Hollis heated pumping well it's not a
it's not an easy industry to get going
in the u.s. North America all a lot of
the snack food companies trail mix
company say they would like North
America
they'd like seed available from North
America they relied on China hey there
was a down year in China two years ago
they didn't produce enough seat
so all these trail mix companies are
crying for crying for seed and all
saying well we want some North America
growers what they don't want and not
they're not willing to have contract you
can't ask the grower to come up with a
million dollars for the harvesters seed
cleaners the seed dryers and all you
need for this crop without having
long-term contracts and so I do have a
few varieties coming out and working
with a with a processing company in
Illinois now on the Hollis pumpkin so
maybe something will come of that
barnaby Lumpkins pretty easy to breed
you know I can't claim I was a genius
working with these I've got a lot of
varieties probably 30 varieties or so
I'll have my germ plasm in high you know
just one of those things you know we're
a squash you know I think I got a total
of nine varieties of squash you know but
I've spent a lot of time breeding squash
and it's for some reason my computer
just won't my great computer won't
accept the changes I'm a change this
table a million times anyway just of it
is when I came in 1967 these are the
number of genes that were described for
these three species if you looked in the
leadership now maybe I might have missed
a few in the literature but but pretty
much this is it and half of them were
described wrongly at the wrong
inheritance model for them or whatever
okay and in 2017 these are just jeans
firm for morphological traits
morphological traits okay it's not
including the genes for disease reserves
but even 2017 approximately 20 genes in
covered a Maxima that you can trace to
morphological traits there
and people and mine and Machado that is
really not much at all
okay most most of the genetics I work
with I'm not gonna say most of I mean I
mean I work with a lot of those genes
but but there's so many so much
variation that I work with this actually
there's no genetic information on it
except what's in my breeding book and so
as a breeder you've got two directions
you could go you know if I find if I
find five traits I can either spend all
my time you know producing isogenic
lines and making the crosses you know to
publish an inheritance study but I can
release some varieties to grow I've made
the selfish choice perhaps to breed
varieties for the growers and maybe I'll
write a book small book sometime just
just detailing you know kind of what I
know about these descriptive
morphological traits and I go back to my
first breeding course was when I was an
undergraduate at Oklahoma State in this
chart and an old breeding book by Allard
I've really struck me you know because
because you see all this variation in
plants and and I was actually doing
special projects for couple breeders and
Oklahoma State at the time and I'm
seeing oh my gosh we have if you had
four recessive genes in a perfect
population this is like your punnett
square perfect population only one out
of 256 plants would have all four of
those genes homozygous okay
in other words true breeding that's just
with four four genes now you're in much
better shape you know about a about a
third if it was all dominant genes about
a third of the plants would would at
least have at least one dominant gene
and you know but and if you're lucky
enough to work with traits with a have
incomplete dominance you're a little
better off because you can see it's
the recessive phenotype the dominant
phenotype in the intermediate phenotype
but in squash this is important because
your population size is limited the
biggest population I ever used in squash
was four hundred and fifty plants for
250 plants a wheat breeder would laugh
at that it was a wheat breeder that that
was teaching his course I was taking you
know of course he he was talking about
populations probably you know f2 3000
wheat plants or something you know you
know in an acre in an acre of squash
breeding where we have guard rows and
different plots and so forth you're
talking six to nine and whether it's
Bush or bond you're talking six to nine
hundred plants you know could be per
acre Zsasz all you can grow you know and
you're not going to devote all that to
just one cross and and so it's quite
restrictive and remember it's not self
pollinating species so any any plant
that we save for the next generation has
the flowers have to be tied off you do
your self pollination and then that
continues the next generation okay and
you can occasionally if like in summer
scores particularly if if you didn't get
a self pollination and you've already
made you know summer squash you're
already selecting what you need you know
by the time you pollinate it because
you're interested in the immature fruit
then that's you could make cuttings and
take those to the greenhouse and
occasionally we have taken cuttings late
to season but often you can't as soon as
the growing point gets again starts to
senesce you can get your cutting to root
but we've tried different hormones and
everything we can't get the growing
point we can we could do it in in tissue
culture but we're not willing to go
there the same way this is just a it's a
simplified example but it kind of shows
what you're up against a lot of the
traits we work with like starts
and seed size and food size some extent
are essentially what we call had a
tea-tray if their quantitative would
call them additive if they're more
qualitative traits we say incomplete
dominance but a since you're talking
about where your where your small a
here's like had zero increment of growth
this one increment growth - incremental
growth of course the different genes you
know don't all affect the trait in the
same way but the point I want to make
here is if you have a quantity trait
that has had at the genetic variation
like in case of starts content it works
out very nice because you know that when
you get your highest starch content in a
population you're likely to have a lot
of homozygosity and this is what we
found and for you if you're breeding a
processor where you want low very low
dry matter content you might be down at
this end if you try to select for if you
make a wide cross with something high
starch low starch then in here you're
going to get some homozygosity some
homozygous lines and and some of them we
can have different combinations which
which would give you the same starch
content but you have a lot of
heterozygosity makes selection very
difficult okay and remember you're
dealing with small populations another
aspect that's important in if I'm
dealing with all three species is
sometimes it's desirable to transfer
traits between the species I'll forget
Maxima times people okay very difficult
to transfer genes there's just too much
stability
I tried this early on and didn't have
any luck and actually why there's some
traits I wanted to transfer between
carpet people acorn squash and butternut
squash
I could never tried for five years to
make that cross and couldn't get it to
work I'll tell you in a second how I got
it finally got it to work but had to use
embryo culture
your carbonyl Maxon mushara if maximum
is a female it's often you can give very
good seed yields in this cross but the
f1 is sterile
okay and so there's a lot of still
externality berries in the next
generation usually you can backcross
using your f1 as a female you can back
cross and but the point I want to make
is is it's not cut and dried you can't
just say well you can cross Maxima time
as chaton know I could I could take 20
lines and I can make this cross some of
them would cross very well some of them
wouldn't cross at all some of them give
some fertility and basically with what
we know maybe when we get molecular
markers and we understand the genes of
control is fine we could we could find
the parents they're going to cross but
it's just a hit miss you know situation
you know we were forced in Maxima that
one of my processing Bush processors
combines very well with my shotta all of
all the virtually all the different
Machado strains cross well with this one
strain of C Maxima but it's not always
to do and I told you I couldn't cross a
cornyn in Machado but I was able to make
a cross of a corn and pumpkin which is
in the other subspecies and I was able
to cross after my shot on I got seven
seeds we were able to culture those and
get five plants out of it and with those
five plants I was able to back cross in
either direction and so why were we
interested in that well acorn squash
have very low carotenoid content
carotenoid is one of the key nutrients
in squash and so this is just work we've
just been doing lately because I just
started working with interspecies
hybrids but anyway we think this is much
higher carotenoid levels both of these
have much higher carotenoid levels then
then we have in acorn squash probably
probably
this one is probably I'd say three or
four times what we usually see so it
really I would upgrade the nutrition if
we could get this level of carotenoid
into acorn acorn squash which is an
important squash acorn butternut and
Buttercup Kubota those are the three
major squash from supermarket so we took
the same squash and crossed to Masada
and got enough seed so we could grow out
15 plants and those plants segregated
for intense pretty intense carotenoid
content and we're able to cross that
with acorn only got a few seeds partial
embryos we're hoping this winter that we
can culture those do an embryo culture
and recover plants to continue that
project I actually first interested in
these interspecies hybrids was to make
cross between Maxima Golden Delicious
and a processing type like large cheese
or Dickenson field and we wanted to see
what the yield would be in the f1 and
the reason for that is we hide I patha
psious that because these f1 hybrids are
sterile they don't produce seeds that we
could increase yield because all the
photosynthate energy could go to the
flesh and not the seed and sure enough
and we got a nice phenotype it's semi
bush because we're crossing bush times
vine and and the yields we're really
quite staggering compared to our check
which was a Dickinson field type I got
from rube seeds the dry matter yield was
almost double in this particular
interspecies hybrids some of them don't
work at all some of them have produced
misshapen fruit another avenue of
research because the interspecies hybrid
even if we get higher yield the
processor is not likely to adopt it
because the difficulties in secret
but so we've been using some of the
interspecies hybrids as rootstocks for
melon to overcome vine decline that
occurs throughout the Northeast and
melon and sure enough we can overcome
that saw borne disease quite easily on
root stocks we can increase yield by 50%
and also extend the growing season we
think this this could be important in
the future well there's not a lot of
milk melon a coverage in New England but
still we're and the seeds a seed
production is again expensive and one of
the things they've been able to do is
we've been able to take some of these
Maxima intermediate Maximus strains and
cross them to but or not and I
originally the idea of this we wanted to
get a butternut shape in maxima and we
just haven't been able to do that just
haven't been able to transfer those
genes back to Maxima but the interesting
thing is through a series of crosses we
did end up with with pretty much
standard butternut and that's only after
a few back cross 3 back crosses to
Machado we since you have a butternut
time
what's advantage this this the seat
fertility is a hundred percent so if if
we can use if we can take this and cross
it back to maxima and we can get 100% of
well-filled seeds you know and if it's
compatible with melon and gives the same
melon yield and disease resistance then
it could be a major breakthrough in the
industry because normally when you make
these crosses a good share the seed is
not filled you go to do it and even with
commercial seed that we've tried you do
the grafting studies and a lot of the
seed doesn't germinate uniformly
I just I'm going to have to go through
this real quick okay but another area
variation is that we look for is in
carbohydrate source the balance of
sugars and starts that's what really
really determines whether a squash is
taste good or is edible there's other
other factors but sugars and starch dog
totally dominate the edibility of squad
and then in terms of vitamin content of
course the carotenoids are and I'm going
to go through this because I'm running
out of time but the thing I want to show
you is it's very expensive to measure
starch content okay takes a lot of
extractions even if you send it off it's
very expensive and you need to send a
lot of material to be analyzed and so we
don't measure starch but the interesting
thing is starch is correlated very
strongly at harvest with the percent dry
way and we know that if you have a
percent dry matter in the squash up
around eighteen to twenty percent your
starch content is going to be around
eight or nine percent and if you have a
squash with that starch content has a
nice pasty texture a very desirable
texture and it's enough starch to
produce high sugar content so results
not good balance of sugar and starch
then the interesting thing is in in the
commercial varieties they fall in the
two most popular or three points popular
commercial varieties they fall into dry
matter contents in in all our trials
they average about 11 percent and I can
I can go to a supermarket in the winter
time or most anytime and I can test
acorn squash from a supermarket not
kabocha squash or butternut acorn squash
and there they test out between nine and
11 percent essentially we would call
these
essentially we would call these in doubt
and so again we so we just get percent
dry matter so we just get these small
samples dry them down determined percent
dry matter sugars are expensive to
measure so we just get soluble solids we
know that correlates with sugar content
we know of soluble solids contents not
above 11% then the squash is not going
to have an adequate balance of sugar
so it makes for for pretty easy
selection and again the dry weight in
squash usually Peaks about 35 days after
pollination as I mentioned before and it
will tend to go down if a squash is
harvested or if the vine and if the line
is senescent too much then actually the
dry matter will tend to degrade and
there's a again a all these squash have
have high dry matter and decent quality
but your commercial varieties would be
you know off the chart the same thing
with sugar we we've selected we've
selected inbred lines that start
degrading starts very early in
development and so about 45 days they're
already reaching soluble solids contents
you know twelve percent or above and so
again it leads to quality and harvest
what's the problem with that and you
know probably finish up on this is that
yield goes down his quality goes up why
is that most of you can answer that
question
squash produces if you have starch
that's the main component okay that's
the main photosynthetic reserve other
than the seed so if you're getting
squash a fruit with a lot of starch in
it okay his requires a lot more
photosynthetic energy and a fruit that
has less starch and so it's not a
one-to-one relationship because because
both fruit have seed in them and maybe
the seed is you
lysing about say 20 to 25% of the
photosynthetic energy is going into seed
develop but most of the rest goes into
fruit in particularly starts development
and so if a grower is growing squash for
the supermarket's I can't convince that
grower to grow my variety that tastes
better if the supermarket his squash
look nice you know and they're going
into the supermarket in there that's
what the supermarket wants
why should he grow a squash that yields
you know less and it's a conundrum and
it makes it very difficult so most of my
varieties I'm releasing we're going to
smaller companies that are willing to
market for local markets they're willing
to market high-end squash I'd like to
get a supermarket chain to market squash
as a variety and then they could they
can introduce a variety that has good
eating quality they would increase their
sales of squash it's difficult to do and
I'll just leave you with a message if
you're gonna if you're in a store and
you want to get an acorn squash to eat
realize that at two weeks after
pollination the ground spot where the
squash was lying on the ground is light
green because it doesn't it doesn't have
the Sun you need the sunlight to get the
chlorophyll synthesis in the in the
Rhine and so if you go into a
supermarket and take a look at this is
what you often if this is a picture I
took in a supermarket usually nowhere is
when you see so when were they squash
harvested probably between 20 and 25
days after fruits 20 to 25 days they're
totally immature there's there's
literally no sugar in them they're low
dry matter they're essentially inedible
you know and yet this is this is what
the stores are and it's not because the
stores don't want quality it's because
they don't they don't know how to
evaluate a fruit like a corn they don't
you know and you can't
converse with him on that I mean it's
just like in your head again so long
this is interesting because this big
chewy actually they deliver of one of
our major supermarket chains they're a
big grower I think you're located there
the locations in Mexico in other areas
and in the fall this was harvest in the
fall so their source of squash in the
fall at least when when you get this
orange brown spot it means the skin has
has accumulated carotenoids in it and
it's probably close to at least 40 days
after fruit set so it's got maximum
starts Clinton might not be too high in
sugar but this squash was actually
edible one say it was top of the line
but was actually edible and this is what
I was going to show you we do all these
cooking tests in and we have tremendous
variation and rotten oil content we've
also done carotenoid profiles we can't
do that all right at the moment because
I don't have access to the lab but what
this profile is allowed us to do we can
identify for instance we can identify
lines that are high in beta-carotene I
can identify them just with the naked
eye and we use this color fan we only
use the last seven colors these colors
don't don't correlate with carotenoid
content and we can only do it with
jakarta Mashhad and maxima the
carotenoids are so low in an acorn that
we can't use it but this is very handy
some of the seed companies I work with
uses color fan it was developed for eggs
and you wonder well why would that work
for squash because eggs eggs contain
xanthophylls i hydroxylated carotenoids
you think it'd be more yellowish but
anyway it works works fine I'm going to
end right there on that thang yep
question far
[Applause]
well I can start with the question do
you guys actually breed for the strength
this dumb when you're looking in your
breeding pumpkins do it okay do I breed
for the stem yeah you actually do
because it's important right and so we
did some research on runes and in
certain varieties will accumulate lignin
and cellulose faster than other but you
have the same problem with with breeding
for stem strength to some extent as you
have for breeding starch content because
the dry matter and the flesh the starts
content in the flesh
it's a storage organ for sugar that
feeds into the stem and helps the stem
to harden okay
and what we found is that varieties
there that are lost in dry matter have
the weakest stems so if you raise the
dry matter in a pumpkin to get better
stem string you tend to lower the yield
Allah but we've gotten around that to
some extent I mean that's just that's a
good question and I might add and in
these shell pumpkins are fanatical
growers there's a there's Association
New Hampshire and I spoke to them a
couple of times well they want answers
you know how can I get the largest
pumpkin and just the physiology of why
these pumpkins go big and just the
physiology of growth in itself it's very
complex you know in terms of what's
going on and cell division and cell size
and I have not given them I've learned
more from these growers and they've
learned from me anyway it's very
interesting and they're always
interested always there's some growth
regulators I can spray on the getting
bigger
any other questions storage content
that's a good question did you hear the
question is there a correlation between
storage and stars insured content so
what happens you know Pumpkins respire
you know when you harvest a pumpkin or
squash it was it was sparse so you put a
squash in storage for one thing the
carotenoid content tends to go up
particularly in the Masada's in create
will increase it depends on the variety
but increases between three weeks to
eight weeks and then and then Peaks so
actually the vitamin content actually
tends to increase in not so much an
acorn but in kabocha and the other thing
that happens is the starts breaks down
into sugar
you have respiration so the starch
starts continued breaks down and you
tend to get a little higher sugar in
storage so the breakdown of starch is
usually precedes faster than the
respiration so you tend to tend to get
higher sugar and like in the butter nuts
sometimes they have to be stored for
some time in order to get the sugar
content upward and balances with start
and what they found in studies and we
followed up on this new zealand's done
the most thorough work on squash because
it's a major export item and the
government actually funds applied work
on squash and what they showed is that
they could they could take squash and
they could treat them with high
temperature like 30 degrees C for five
or six days and that accelerated the
enzymes which break down starch and and
then they could take that squash and put
it back in the preferred storage
temperature say 10 degrees centigrade
and then the degradation that would
continue because when they ship their
squash to Japan and it reaches the pan
it's going to be a minimum a 20% dry
matter and a minimum of 11% soluble
solids so that were
important so now when my squash comes
into the greenhouse I tell her the
greenhouse manager I said bump up the
temperature for a week you know because
I have to get the sugar content and my
Mashhad is cuz I'm working with a
company in New Zealand I got its in situ
them so I got a I got a to cooking test
on those squash and so that's an
important thing thing to understand now
it used to be that they they did that
the whole squash and they do it with
sweet potato as you Karam it turns out
this course don't have to be cured for
disease or anything like that because
you know 55 60 degrees you know they're
they can actively get Corky layers to
prevent disease is really not much
different but it turns out if you want
to get if you want to sell your squash
until growers if you want to sell your
butternut squash you're growing the
Waltham variety which happens to be very
low in sugar and harvest most popular
variety as the lowest sugar harvest
approximately any variety of looked at
and so I say well bump up the
temperatures you know when you put them
in the greenhouse for a week or whatever
and pump up the temperature and at least
you can start marketing them within
three or four weeks and the customers
are going to be satisfied if you eat a
squash it doesn't have a balance of
sugar in it even if it's fairly low dry
matter it's like eating a dog ball just
not good that was a good question yes
well that's a question I probably can't
answer the question was how much does
environmental stress affect rotten wood
content I guess it would depend on women
from environmental stress occurred but
early on I would say would you don't
need that much sugar you know as a
substrate for Grotta noise because the
total content micrograms compared to
sugar content so you know some of the
highest brought annoy contents are in
fruit with with only 6 percent dry
matter the Dickinson feel
type I would think an environmental
stress but environmental stress
if you leave your leaf area since you
can get a storage other thing I might
add blind eyes it turns out to
respiration no one's ever looked into
this work done and seen this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu